a nail art is a great way to express
yourself and your individuality there
are so many cool nail designs from
tie-dye too flashy decals but there are
other nail trends that should never see
the light of day if you're new to our
channel please subscribe and give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we're talking about 50 nail trends that
should not exist spiral nails spiral
nails is an accent piece is fine but
when people began putting spirals on
each and every nail is when the trend
went a bit too far
simple things like running your fingers
through your hair would turn into a
disaster when strands of hair get
tangled in each and every loop extra
long nails the extra long nail trend has
been around for years but we really wish
it would disappear forever having nails
this long makes life so much more
difficult typing texting and even
driving a car would be a challenge
character designs character designs are
super cute but this nail trend is just a
bit too childish if you want someone to
take you seriously
having spongebob artwork on your nails
is not the way to go
spiky nails it's the only positive thing
about bees nails is they would come in
handy if you needed to protect yourself
from a knife wielding bandit just shove
one spiky nail into your sail inside and
make a run for it money nails it's never
cool to show off how much money you have
and it's definitely not cool to flaunt
your cash on your nails we could think
of a million other ways to use money and
none of them include this nail art trend
aquarium nails when people started
sporting many fish tanks on their nails
we were confused and a little bit
intrigued these nails are actually
filled with water which means this nail
trend is an accident waiting to happen
breaking a nail means you'll have water
gushing all over your outfit
3d nails 3d nail art was a trend that
definitely should have it never existed
walking around with massive designs
jaggedly poking out from every single
nail draws attention to your fingers but
not in a good way
contoured nails some trends are a hit
while others are a mess like this
contoured nail trend with just one strip
of nail polish down the center and the
sides left bare this trend makes it look
like you started painting your nails and
then you got too lazy to finish stiletto
nails these nails look more like claws
than stilettos anyone who comes with
a few inches of these stiletto nails is
guaranteed to end up getting scratched
caviar nails have you ever tried caviar
it's pretty yummy but this delicate
ascension we left on your plate not on
your nails sure this trend doesn't
include real caviar but the tiny
sprinkles give the nails a bubbly effect
that makes this trend and absolute no no
here snail pierced nails look cool the
piercing holes through your nails and
shoving earrings and other charms
through them is damaging and dangerous
the little charms can snag on sweaters
and completely rip off your nail sounds
pretty painful right duck nails duck
nails start off like any other nails but
then they flare out towards the tip
giving the appearance of duck feet ducks
are cute and all but every time we see a
set of duck nails we can't help but to
laugh and shout out quack quack pom pom
nails while wearing pom pom nails what
happens when you take a shower or go for
a swim are you walking around with
soaking wet pom-poms for hours
afterwards we'll never find out because
this is one trend we will never try
funny nails furry nails may look cool
but you can imagine how difficult it
would be to wipe after using the
restroom things are bound to get messy
bubble nails these bubble nails freak us
out walking around with bulging humps on
your fingers is never good luck they
kind of look like a mutation from a
far-off galaxy have you ever tried any
of the nail trends on our list
be honest leave us a comment down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
you